hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast outer membrane remodeling of
insinuated Salmonella to create a
mucosal vaccine against Acinetobacter
baumannii i presented by dr. james Galen
professor Center for vaccine development
University of Maryland Baltimore
I am Xavier Gutierrez of lab routes and
I will be your moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
routes
lab routes is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars now before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want any time you want
during the presentation just click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen
and type your questions into the
drop-down box that appears on the screen
our speaker will respond to your
questions via email if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the ask a question box
to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and those offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Gailen I will now turn the presentation
over to him well thank you very much for
the opportunity to speak to you all this
afternoon we are going to be talking
about a concept called carrier vaccines
carrier vaccines are typically vaccines
that are engineered from a bacteria to
express foreign antigens from unrelated
human pathogens expressed in this
vaccine strain typically we prefer to
use vaccine strains derived from human
pathogen
and not human commensals because human
pathogens are exquisitely adapted for
invasion into mucosal tissue and
triggering immune responses where
commensals typically are not adapted to
do those things so the the bacteria of
the human pathogen that we've chosen to
work with is Salmonella typhi which is
the causative agent of typhoid fever and
we have engineered salmonella typhi to
be an attenuated vaccine strain and we
have further adapted that to become a
carrier vaccine so what are the key
requirements for developing bacterial
life carrier vaccines well first of all
since our vaccines are intended for
human vaccination they have to be
clinically acceptable in other words
they have to be safe and immunogenic and
so we have we started out this project
many years ago with CVD 908 H tra which
has been proven safe and immunogenic and
Phase two human clinical trials for
reasons I will try to get into here CVD
908 H tra was not a good vaccine strain
to adapt to become a carrier vaccine so
I reengineering a strain called CBD 910
with attenuation comparable to the
clinically acceptable CBD 908 H tra the
second thing we need is we need
efficient for an antigen expression so
over the years we have developed
patented non-antibiotic plasmid
selection technology obviously we were
not going to we're not going to want to
use plasmids that require antibiotic
selection when we're trying to target a
human pathogen for which antibiotics use
of antibiotics has caused problems in
the first place
also we've we have over the years
developed patented antigen export
technology which is going to be the
primary focus of the talk today and last
but certainly not least we need
acceptable preclinical animal models for
testing and refining the immunogenicity
of vaccine strands this is really
important if you spend years developing
engineered strains but you don't have an
animal challenge model it's going to be
very hard for you to get into the clinic
so you need acceptable animal models and
we have to at this point we have a
murine Mouse mucosal ie intranasal
immunization model and we have actually
expanded this international intranasal
model to cover non-human primates and
we'll go through some of this technology
and send the animal models as we proceed
in this talk so I gotta say the the road
to developing a live or oh carrier
vaccine has been very very very long and
it has also been quite a ride when I
first got into this field a couple of
decades ago now I have decades there
really weren't that many tools available
so as the years have gone by we've had
to create a lot of the tools that we've
needed so first thing I want to talk
about is if we're gonna we're talking
about carrier vaccines right so we need
to express these foreign antigens in a
way that the immune system can see these
antigens and mount the appropriate
immune response against these foreign
antigens okay so what are the factors
affecting this immunogenicity of foreign
antigens it's very important to
understand that the carrier vaccine
typically does not benefit from
expression of these foreign antigens for
example we're going to talk in this
we're going to discuss in this
presentation development of an anthrax
vaccine where we target protective
antigen PA 83 from anthrax toxin so
we're going to express PA a 3 in our
carrier vaccine now if Salmonella typhi
we're sapote was supposed to be
expressing PA 83 naturally it would
already be doing so
but it doesn't and therefore when we
come in an engineer hyper expression of
this antigen we typically increase the
metabolic burden on the strain which is
already attenuated and if we
inappropriately overexpress these
foreign antigens we end up with a
vaccine strain which is so attenuated
that it's very safe in clinical trials
but it has no immunogenicity and we'll
talk about this and the last thing that
it's taken a few a few years to figure
out is that exported or surface
expressed foreign antigens are more
immuno genic than cytoplasmic Lee
expressed foreign antigens which are
expressed inside the carrier vaccine
strain so we want these antigens to be
on the surface and not inside the
organism okay alright so let's look at
attenuation here over the years a number
of attenuated Salmonella typhi vaccine
strains have been developed just as
vaccine strains not as carrier vaccines
okay and what we've found over the years
that is that over attenuated strains
okay are poorly immunogenic so if the
strain is too weak then it doesn't
really reach the appropriate immune
inductive sites and you get a very safe
vaccine which is not immunogenic okay
in sufficiently attenuated vaccine
strains are extremely immuno genic
but they're reacted genex so they make
you feel that you get clinical symptoms
unacceptable clinical reactogenicity is
the way we like to call it okay so the
key is to achieve the right balance
between attenuation and immunogenicity
and this is shown very clearly in the
next slide which brings up another point
that I want to discuss ok so balanced
foreign antigen expression will enhance
the immunogenicity of a lot of carrier
backs
so the top panel here a B and C you can
see a vaccine strain which is very very
very reactive genic is also immuno genic
but it's to react to genex so the safety
is unacceptable okay when you engineer
when you end when you attenuate the
vaccine string so that it's not reactor
genic it's not immuno genic okay and so
what you have to do is you have to you
have to approach just the right balance
between safety and immunogenicity okay
but this is a problem because the
perfect vaccine strain is already
metabolically balanced so when we come
in with foreign antigen expression we
destroy that balance and that's why
developing carrier vaccines has been so
difficult so a B and C address how to
make a vaccine string but what if we
want to make a carrier vaccine out of
that beautifully balanced vaccine strain
okay so what we what I've figured out
over the years is you want to start with
a vaccine strain which is slightly react
to genic if you overexpress an extra
high levels of foreign antigen it
becomes over attenuated and so it's
nonreactive genic but it's also not
immunogenic so you have to adjust
antigen expression just right so that
you get a balance between safety and
immunogenicity against both the carrier
vaccine and the foreign antigen and this
is tough this is this is hard to do okay
so our vaccine strain that we started
with remember I said I had to go back
and over a re-engineer a vaccine strain
because our original backs
strain CD 908 Acra was perfectly
balanced but then when we started
expressing foreign antigens it became
over attenuated so I went back and
engineered a strain called CBD 910 okay
it's engineered from the same wild-type
typhoid strain ty2 as CBD 908 H tra came
from and also the currently licensed
typhoid vaccine strain T y21 a comes
from the parent strains T y2 okay CBD
910 contains precise genetic deletions
in chromosomal si gua ba and h tra this
is this is important because what this
means is our vaccine strains are
attenuated metabolically but any known
or unknown virulence factors that are
present and typhi are still in our
vaccine strains so these vaccine strains
go in after immunization of a host they
go in ready to do what they've always
done but they because of the metabolic
attenuation they run out of gas and so
therefore you don't see a disease state
after immunization because that would be
bad for a vaccine okay so the
attenuation of cp910 was confirmed in
bouncy mice according to standard ld50
assays and our ld50 lethal dose 50 a
safe or CBD 910 was equivalent to CBD
908 H tra so therefore we feel that CBD
910 is a clinically acceptable strain
but that of course has to be
demonstrated in clinical trials phase 1
clinical trials okay so this slide is
going to frame the rest of the
presentation today okay so we have a
vaccine strain but we now have to get
all of the antigen expression technology
into place the appropriate antigen
expression technology in order to
develop a carrier vaccine from
CVD 910 the vaccines trained the parent
vaccine strain so what do you need to
develop what kind of expression
technology do you need okay well first
first of all plasmids are going to fit
in very nicely into development of
carrier vaccines and plasmids are
notoriously unstable in Salmonella typhi
so you need a plasmid partitioning
system to guarantee stable inheritance
of these please expression plasmids into
dividing daughter cells at CBD 910 if
you lose the plasmid in vivo you lose
the ability to make foreign antigen so
you may get an a really good antibody
response or an immune response against
the live vector of the carrier vaccine
but you won't get any immune recognition
of the foreign antigen because the
plasmids gone okay second thing which
we've alluded to is we need an antigen
export system so that we get high level
expression of actual vaccine antigens on
the outside of the cell the third thing
which I got dragged kicking and
screaming into the development of was a
non antibiotic plasmid selection system
because in the good old days when things
were very simple in the laboratory you
can have plasmids and your e coli
strains and you can select them with
antibiotics and every cell has the
plasmid and it's lovely and life is
grant well you can't use antibiotics in
an oral vaccine intended for human
administration especially if you're
trying to combat an antibiotic resistant
pathogen so you have to develop a
plasmid selection system that no longer
uses antibiotics and that that took a
few that took some time and then last
but not least we've had to also develop
chromosomal expression systems because
we realized if we want to express more
than one antigen in a single carrier
vaccine you're not going to be able to
put all of those on a plasma because the
plasmid will be huge and it's sonst
it'll be disappearing again you end up
with non immunogenic beautifully
engineered carrier vaccines but they
don't work okay so so let's look at
plasmid partitioning and antigen export
let's look at that a little bit more
detail all right okay so we have several
hypotheses for engineering multivalent
Salmonella typhi carrier vaccine okay so
this is my great hypothesis part one
okay
live vectors derive little or no benefit
from expression of foreign antigens okay
and in fact these foreign antigens may
be harmful if they're expressed
intracellularly because they may block
anabolic functions or a number of other
ways not to mention the fact that if you
have high level expression of
intracellular antigens if the level of
expression is too high then they start
to improperly fold and then they form
inclusion bodies and inclusion bodies
will not present the right if necessary
conformational e specific antigens and
you won't get that and therefore the
again you you've you have a vaccine
that's beautifully engineered but it
doesn't work okay so so what we ended up
deciding to do after a long time was we
ended up first going with a low copy
number expression plasmid okay so in the
like I referred to the good old days you
know we used to use high copy number PUC
plasmids and and and life was just grand
you throw in a little o iptg and bang
you've got tons of antigen you can't do
that in a live vector system because of
the balance that we're trying to achieve
here so we actually found that when we
appropriately expressed antigen at the
right levels from low copy number
plasmids we actually ended up getting
superior immune responses okay so we
need a low copy number expression
plasmid RS was derived from plasma
called SC 101 it has an
1:01 repla Khan it's about five copies
per chromosomal equivalent next thing we
need is plasmids are not chromosomes
okay and so for the most part plasmids
will when a daughter cell along gates
and divides the plasmids will be
passively inherited just by random
stumps sequestering into daughter cells
that's not good enough for live vector
of four live carrier vaccines so we
needed a stable inheritance system
called par a and I would really love to
get into the details on this it's really
it's fabulous stuff but I I I don't have
the time here but anyway this
partitioning system pushes copies of the
plasmid into daughter cells it's
fabulous stuff okay again we need an
inducible antigen expression system
full-bore always on constitutive
expression in a carrier vaccine remember
we're trying to get balance okay
constitutive or expression it does not
work it over attenuates the strain you
get nothing
okay so we need an inducible antigen
expression system so we have chosen the
OP c promoter okay which is osmotically
controlled so when ozma the osmolarity
is high it turns on when the osmolarity
is low it turns off okay and we also
have this antigen export technology
which is called cly a-okay
and as i referred to earlier in the
presentation we're focusing on PA 83
which is protective antigen 83 killa
Dalton from anthrax toxin that project
has allowed us to develop a lot of this
technology all right but I got to show
you this slide because this is really
cool okay so we started working with a
protein called qui a Clio mediates
foreign antigen export okay and
it can mediate either surface expression
or outright secretion by outer membrane
vesicles into the into the supernatant
extracellular medium all right so when I
first developed this export technology I
wanted to see if clay could actually do
this and so I focused on it on a protein
called sack B and for some of you that
have used sack be in enteric bacteria
engineering sack beasts is makes it an
enzyme called leave and sucrase leave an
sucrase has this remarkable ability to
take sucrose it cleaves it into glucose
and leaves fructose but because leaving
sucrase doesn't have anything else to do
it doesn't have any meetings to go to or
anything so it takes the fructose and
links it together because it has not
anything else to do and produces this
long polymer called leave an okay and
leave an almost looks like a capsule
it's like this gloppy mess all right if
Sac B makes leave an intracellularly
you've got dead bugs but if Sac B ends
up on the outside of the cell then if
it's exposed to sucrose it makes leave
an and the leave and coats the outside
of the cell so what we did was we made a
genetic fusion of clay a to Sac B to
test the hypothesis that clay could move
a large foreign antigen domain out to
the surface of clay and then we plated
these these transform cells onto sixteen
percent sucrose okay so on the left
you've got bacteria plated on a 16
percent sucrose plate where they express
clay what they express clay a but it's
not fused to Sac B okay so the bacteria
grow fine now if
ia was not able to efficiently move sack
B out to the surface when I played cells
containing clay a stack B you should get
dead
you should get nothing growing on the
plate but that's not what happened
okay and so you've got these cells that
are making a huge amount of leave an and
in fact if you look carefully at the
plate
I bumped the right side of the plate
before I took the picture and the leave
and goo flowed over to the right I mean
we're talking about a tremendous amount
of leave in here so this this showed me
very clearly that cly is indeed able to
transport foreign antigen domains to the
surface quite efficiently okay and so
when I saw that plate I thought ha we're
in business all right
but NIH doesn't care about expression of
clay and sack B on the surface itself so
we had to like do something relevant
here so what we did in back to PA 83 we
ended up making a vaccine against
anthrax targeting protective antigen
from anthrax toxin and in this slide in
panel a you can seek Salmonella typhi
this is an electron micrograph okay
gold labeling the gold labeling is
targeting PA 83 okay
and you can see clay PA 83 ends up on
the outside of the cell exactly as
intended okay and yet when you look at
gold labeling of Salmonella typhi
carrier vaccines expressing cytoplasmic
PA 83
obviously as expected it doesn't end up
on the surface
okay so clay is not only able to move
stack B out to the surface but it's able
to also move protective antigen 83 which
is a much more relevant antigen for the
real world
it moves that out to the surface as well
now remember I said if you've got to
carry your vaccine
you're all dressed up but you don't have
anywhere to go then you've got some some
nice engineering but it doesn't really
mean anything unless you test it in a
clinically relevant animal model okay
and so we did a lot of preliminary
testing in mice and we found that
antibody responses against PA a3 were
very very they were excellent okay but
because we had access to some primates
from NIH we conducted a non-human
primate intranasal model of the images
Jannetty study and you noticed that this
the study went on for a hundred and
thirty days it was a very long
experiment but it worked really well and
what we ended up finding out was that
when you immunize cinema legis monkeys
intranasally on day zero and 14 with our
carrier vaccine expressing cly a PA 83
and you look for toxin neutralizing
antibody okay which is on the y-axis
here after two doses you get nothing
okay and so we knew ahead of time that
the best way to produce excellent immune
responses was with heterologous prime
boosting where you your your antigen pia
83 is delivered to a host in two
different forms
okay so heterologous prime boosting in
this particular setting was carried out
by intranasal mucosal immunization with
the live vector allied the carrier
vaccine and parenteral boosting with
purified pia 83 all right so the blue
arrows show that after two intranasal
doses of carrier vaccine no obvious
toxin neutralizing antibody was detected
okay but then on day 100 we boosted
parentally with alum adjuvanted p83
and the immune responses were excellent
after that and what's really interesting
is if you look at the if you look at the
orange inverted triangles that's the
immune response against let's see let me
get this straight
that's the intranet that's the immune
response against interest cell cellular
Lee expressed PA 83 but if you look at
the the blue curve here
that's the antibody response against
extracellular Lee at surface expressed P
83 so again this slide demonstrates in a
non-human primate model that surface
expressed proteins are more immunogenic
than cytoplasmic li expressed proteins
okay alright so so now we're coming back
to the same slide that frames this this
the rest of this talk now let's look at
the animal the non-antibiotic plasmid
selection system this was the project
that i got dragged into kicking and
screaming because i this was going to be
tough how do you select for a plasmid
without using antibiotics okay and what
we ended up choosing was a that called
SSB that encodes single stranded binding
protein and single stranded binding
protein is essential for all living
cells if you don't make SSB you did okay
and if you look at this slide because I
always like I got there's two things
that I always have to do in a
presentation I always have to present a
plasmid which calms me down and makes me
more confident and I always have to
present a crystal structure diagram side
because it's just cool alright so if you
look at this crystal structure slide
here you see this little ribbon of white
that goes all through these tetra Mirza
messes
that's the single stranded binding
protein so SSB binds to single-stranded
DNA and keeps it single-stranded which
is very very important for DNA
replication recombination and repair and
so if you don't make SSB then you can't
do DNA replication recombination and
repair and you don't have life and I
don't I don't have a chance to go
through the details of this but you can
imagine that if we tried to delete SSB
from the chromosome of our typhi vaccine
strain and then put that SSB on a
plasmid and then introduce that plasmid
into SSB - strains you can see where
this could get a little bit complicated
and it was in fact very complicated but
it actually did work and we got the
system working correctly and so we were
then able to test this to find out what
does it do does it actually retain
maintain plasmid and so we published
this paper back and I think 2010 Wow
time flies when you having fun and and
sure enough we got some really very very
interesting data okay now this was back
in 2010 so we were still using 908 H tra
as the the attenuated vaccine string
okay and what we did was we did
intranasal immunization of mice on day 0
and 14 again intramuscular boosted mice
on day 42 with purified Pia 83 so this
is a heterologous prime boost strategy
and we measured humoral responses
against PA 83 okay so in this table here
let's just look at CBD 908 H tra
carrying our expression classman okay
and you notice the expression plasma has
a copy number of about 15 the foreign
antigen being expressed is cly APA 83
there's no SSB stabilization okay on day
41 right before the boost okay the
humoral immune response was 80 in terms
of the lousy units okay on day 48 one
week after the
it went up to about 14,000 okay now
notice that when we bring in the SSB
stabilization system on a 15 per copy
plasmid okay Dave 41 pre boost was 25
and the day 48 one week post boost
dropped tenfold and I thought oh man
okay so on the surface of it it didn't
work right all right however I realized
that and I sort of saw this coming in to
this once you take a multi copy plasma
and you stabilize it so that the the the
carrier vaccine has to keep that plasma
okay the good news is that if you have a
good stabilization system the plasmids
are stabilized but the bad news is if
those plasmids are encoding an antigen
at too high a level and you get
metabolic burden your antibody responses
will drop so we went to 908 H GRA s SB
with five copies per plasmid cly a PA 83
fusion s SB notice on day 41 before we
get to the boost it's already gone up to
2300 and then one week post boots that
goes to 156 thousand and then when we
went to a less attenuated background
strand here again metabolic burden this
is a healthier strain I know eighty is
more is healthy or less attenuate than
908 H GRE remember that balance we
talked about okay Dave 41 pre boost was
now almost 5000 but then after one week
after post boost it went up to a half a
million so when I saw these data I
realized SSB is the way to go for engine
expression from a low copy number
stabilized plasma okay last but not
least chromosomal expression systems
okay the second part of the hypothesis
here this is hypothesis for engineering
immunogenic multivalent Salmonella tied
the carrier vaccines part two we whole
we hypothesized that it's unlikely that
immunogenic and protective multivalent
live vector vaccines expressing more
than one foreign antigen using only
plasmids you're not going to get away
with it they're gonna be too big and
they're gonna be unstable okay all right
so therefore if you can't get them all
on a plasma what do you do and the
answer is you go you start integrating
some of these antigens into the
chromosome okay however because you've
integrated into the chromosome your gene
dosage drops so if you're on a five copy
per plasmid okay you've got five copies
of your foreign antigen that are
independently expressing if you go to
the chromosome you only have one copy so
therefore it's likely that you're going
to have to have multiple integrations
into the chromosome to get the antigen
expression that you want okay all right
so I'm just going to go through this
very briefly this this was a concept
project that we we wanted to find out
well if you use instead of a foreign
antigen if you use green fluorescent
protein as your reporter is it true that
when you integrate into multiple loci
you get an additive effect and you get
higher levels of expression okay and so
we integrated into the Gua be a locus
all right and we got a mean fluorescence
of 32 we integrated it into the HDR a
locus and we got a mean fluorescence of
24 but we integrated it into both low
sigh indeed we saw an additive effect
and it went up to 48 okay so this this
encouraged us that multiple integrations
sites in the chromosome would be the way
to express appropriate levels of a
single foreign antigen cassette and so
with with nine with
with CBD 910 we come up with this
plausible design for a for a carrier
vaccine expressing up to four engines if
each one of these antigens only needs a
little bit of expression we can
integrate into Gua bah tra our POS or a
plasmid and you notice the SSB
stabilizing that plasmid and SSB is
knocked out of the chromosome okay all
right now I had to throw this slide in
because I've never seen this before it's
really cool we did not know this before
we started looking at it but we started
you know because you know what if I need
for chromosomal loci I have a BA HT RA
you know our POS but what if I needed
yet one more integration site that I
knew in activation of that locus wasn't
going to further attenuate the strain
and I chose we started looking at the
Clio locus and so here again we've got a
knob see cassette driving GFP expression
integrated into the clay a locus where
we've kept the promoter for cly a intact
this is the strategy that we've used
with all of our integrations into the
chromosome the the target locus of the
chromosome we always keep the promoter
so if we integrate it into Guam ba we
keep the globby a promoter if we
integrate it into HTR a would keep the
HDR a promoter in this case we kept the
Clio motor and this was very very
interesting in line and in in line one
here liquid 25 milli molar sodium
chloride okay so that's non the IMC
promoters theoretically turned off okay
we've got a mean fluorescence of 33 when
we grew the strain in liquid and we
induced with 150 milli molar sodium
chloride the mean fluorescence went up
to 76 but I expected it to be higher
than that and we started to think about
it so we took the same strain and we
plated it on solid liquid a solid
lb medium with low salt which turns out
to turn on the clay a promoter which we
didn't know this until we ran this
experiment and then the fluorescence
jumped to 131 that that was that was a
big surprise and then when we played it
on solid media with a hundred and fifty
mili molar sodium chloride in other
words inducing conditions where both the
Clio promoter and the MC promoter are on
we got very high fluorescence of almost
two hundred so this this showed me that
cly a could be another locus for
integration but a very special locus
where clay a promoters would only turn
on upon solid phase induction in other
words let's say colonization of the host
okay alright so why am i interested in
all these exotic promoters there okay
what we really don't want when we
immunize a host is we don't want all the
antigens to be expressed at the same
time because here again we go back to
this balance if we over attenuate the
strain due to heavy antigenic expression
we don't we have a strain that's not
immunogenic what we'd really like to do
is have the antigen in to induced at
various phases of colonization and
immune as you know that would be
expected in the immunization process so
that antigens get expressed a little at
a time as the vaccine strain starts to
take hold and starts to reach inductive
sites so you can see after oral
immunization we can envision a situation
where when the when when the organism
reaches the gastrointestinal tract the
stomach you get osmolarity induced okay
for antigen one if you had antigen two
integrated into the HTR a locus you may
also have a heat shock response when it
hits that acid barrier okay so you can
see more antigen being expressed
okay as the live vector as the carrier
vaccine makes its way into the
gastrointestinal tract you may get some
temporary colonization Kleist olive
phase induction claw a may be induced
may be making more antigen - okay we're
we're gradually introducing foreign
antigen expression geared towards the
metabolism of the live vector itself
that's the key that we're trying to
achieve here okay
as the dab after colonization there may
be an exponential phase where the cells
really start to grow that induces the
Gua ba locus and you may start to in
express let's say for an antigen three
you see this gradual introduction of
antigen expression based on
environmentally relevant signals okay
and then finally the the organisms may
reach some sort of stationary phase
that'll trigger the rpoS promoter a
little bit more antigen 3 in this
example okay so it's gradual expression
okay so to make a long story short
eventually the bio defense funding kind
of dried up and we were not able to take
our anthrax vaccine into clinical trials
so the bad news was we never really got
to be able to test this in a clinical
trial but the good news was that the
technology that was developed for this
carrier vaccine is applicable to any
pathogen okay and so we decided to move
on and target Acinetobacter baumannii i
which the cdc declared in 2013 was a
serious threat to public health because
of its resistance to multiple classes of
antibiotics okay and the World Health
Organization just released a report in
twenty
17 declaring that Acinetobacter
baumannii guy is at the top of the list
for concerns for multi drug-resistant
pathogens okay so the project that we've
developed at this point and I'm in the
process of coaxing NIH to believe that
this is a fabulous project we want to
develop a bivalent mucosal vaccine where
we target outer membrane proteins I'm
paying on W Ave outer membrane protein a
and I'm W outer membrane protein W have
been proven in mouse experiments to be
challenging experiments to be protective
against a challenge with bomani i okay
and obviously we want to express these
outer membrane proteins on the surface
of the bacteria and in this particular
case we want to target extracellular
export of these outer membrane proteins
all right the problem is that I'm Pei
has this annoying tendency to grab onto
peptidoglycan and stabilize the outer
membrane so overexpression of ave might
be problematic for vesicles because it's
holding onto the peptidoglycan all right
so we've had to engineer a version of
bombay in which that interaction doesn't
happen anymore and this is the way the
vesicle delivery system might look so
we've got CVD 910 SSB stabilized now CVD
910 makes its own copy of on peg that's
on Bay St here in the green so if we
brought in aren't they from
Acinetobacter baumannii i we might be
able to produce outer membrane vesicles
here when we brought in a plasmid that
expressed some sort of outer membrane
vesicle protein inducing protein for a
for example cly a or later on we'll talk
about pag oh all right
but because the op a gene may be
coordinating with the peptidoglycan the
purple layer there we may get low levels
of expression of the vesicles
okay so what if we delete the OP a from
type Salmonella typhi and pretend
Express i'm peg from Acinetobacter in
its place if we engineer that operate
from Acinetobacter so that it no longer
interacts with the purple peptidoglycan
layer then we may get more vesicle
formation if we bring in hyper vesicular
teams like ly a or pag el alright and
here this is the ps2 lizzie stones if
you have delta obey from st so that it's
not making its own ave its expressing
foreign on pay from Acinetobacter
instead and outer membrane protein w
from Acinetobacter by money i then you
could get bivalent vesicle formation and
delivery to the immune system and this
is this is what we're attempting to
engineer first thing we have to
demonstrate is that we have surface
expression of an outer membrane protein
from as native actor Bahmani i and so we
did surface labeling experiments with
nine ten expressing a beyond bay
hopefully on the surface using antibody
specific for pompeii okay so we used we
targeted antibody against table a and
then we had a alexa 486 as a secondary
fluorescent reporter okay and as you
would expect antibodies against Pompey
from bomani I do not crush do not cross
react with Salmonella typhi on face so
there's no fluorescence here and we
introduced our low copy number
expression plasmid expressing altered on
pay from a B so that it's been
engineered not to interact with the
peptidoglycan layer we get very very
good expression on the surface okay
however we decided we wanted to do an
experiment where we permeable eyes the
CVD 910 expressing a beyond peg so this
allows anybody to get all the way into
the the the periplasmic space so the
idea is what is the maximum amount of
Pompeii that we can detect whether it's
on the surface or buried inside the the
periplasm and you notice the overlap
between the the green curve and the
yellow curve we're getting about 60%
surface expression of Bombay which which
I thought was really quite good and what
really surprised me is when we did this
Acinetobacter baumannii I positive
control we get a mean fluorescence
that's just about the same as CVD 9/10
expressing a B on face so this is a very
encouraging slide because this is very
encouraging data we've actually been
able to engineer a type II strain so
that it looks like a bomani eye strain
on the outside because it's making a lot
of fascinating bacter bomani I obey so
this was very encouraging in Chand and
it shows clearly that when we leased
from Bay when we express an outer
membrane protein from bomani I and
indeed is able to transport he
transported this surface alright so this
slide gets a little complicated but it
shows clearly that to get a B on Bay to
the surface is that's fine but if you
can't export it in vesicles then you
have a problem alright now this is where
I need to emphasize remember cly a makes
outer membrane vesicles okay it's
hemolytic and it makes it has two
functions its hemolytic and if you
express it at high levels it makes that
remember in vesicles as well so what we
did here was we wanted to find out if we
use cly a as an outer membrane vesicle
system inducing outer membrane vesicles
we'll the hemolytic activity of those
classic ago up in various backgrounds
which I'll explain in a minute
the idea being with if the hemolytic
activity goes up and these 910 strains
are also expressing a beyond pay the
inference is that the on pay is going
out as well because the vesicle export
is increasing okay so I'm using clay as
a reporter here for function can you get
a be on base seeded vesicles off the
surface of CVD 910 alright so if you
look at Lane one PBS control there's no
hemolytic activity because clay isn't
being made CVD 910 by itself
there's no clay being hyper expressed if
you bring in P SEC 10 expressing clay a
you get an increase in hemolytic
activity and this is the 910 strain that
I talked about where they deliver the
deletion of wild-type on paved messed IV
has been deleted from this drain you
bring in clay and in fact the hemolytic
activity does indeed go up so if you
take away the on pay gene all together
you can make more vesicles here we have
in Lane five we have a carrier vaccine
where the st on pay is gone we've
integrated a beyond pay into the guapi a
locus okay so these are exponentially
growing cells in this particular Lane we
put in the clay hyper expression and
indeed the hemolytic activity goes up
even more so when I saw the that
particular data from that Lane I
realized I'm pain needs to be expressed
in Thai feet for Tai Chi to be able to
efficiently make outer membrane vesicles
you have to have on fate present okay
and then in Lane six we integrated the
ABI Bay into the rpoS locus okay you
notice hemolytic activity went down
remember our POS is induced in
stationary phase okay these cells were
harvested in exponential phase and so
that hemolytic activity went down but if
you
harvest the cells and stationery phrase
face remember all of these panels are
corrected for cell densities so we use
the same number of cells in these assays
the hemolytic activity is very high and
this was really surprising to me because
this is the first time that a foreign
antigen a beyond pay expression in a
Thai key strain can be shown to benefit
the vaccine strain I've never seen that
before because typically when you
express foreign antigens it's it's an
energy drain it's a carbon drain and the
book the back the vaccine gets no
benefit from it but in this particular
case I've managed to demonstrate that a
biame in place of s T on pay actually
benefits the cell that the vaccine
strain it's also a vaccine string okay
however for vaccinating human beings
okay hang in there I'm almost done
from vaccinating human beings the FDA
tends to like get nervous when you're
high over expressing virulence proteins
like hemolytic hemolysis like clay and
so I needed a system for inducing outer
membrane vesicles that was safe non
hemolytic and this is when we discovered
Pedigo which is an outer membrane
protein Pagal is very special it's a DA
Solis that converts lipid a from a
highly reacted genic hex isolated moiety
to a detoxified Penta isolated so
instead of six instead of six acyl
groups there's only five and this is a
less reacted genic form of lipid a
alright and surprisingly they did that
it was discovered in 2016 reported that
overexpression Pagal causes outer
membrane vesicle formation all right so
we wanted to find out if Pagal actually
did induce
outer membrane vesicle formation in our
carrier vaccine CVD 910 okay so this is
a test of function slide here again
we're using hemolytic activity again but
in this particular case we're using
chromosomally expressed cly a so
remember there's a drop and copy number
now because it's only in the chromosome
okay one copy per cell and we're just
seeding the membrane with cly a so that
if we can get vesicles to form they will
be hemolytic alright so in Lane one PBS
control no hemolysis Lane to CBD 910 no
hemolysis CVD 910 Delta Gua Bao MC ka no
hemolysis because we're not making
enough to make vesicles we're just
seating the the membrane with cly a as a
phenotypic reporter and then when we
brought in pag L version 1 I'll get to
that in a minute
we saw outstanding hemolytic activity
then we saw a reduction in activity with
version 2 and we saw the lowest amount
of activity in version 3 so what is
version 1 2 & 3 we engineered the
ribosome binding site in front of Pedigo
so that version 1 is an optimized
ribosome binding site so we get lots of
peg L version 2 is a less efficient
ribosome binding site so we get less pag
L less hemolytic activity and version 3
was an unwise ribosomal binding site and
we got the lowest expression pag L and
the lowest hemolytic activity so this
shows very clearly that Pagal indeed in
an inducible fashion is able to mediate
vesicular hyper vesicular of outer
membrane vesicles off of CBD 910 and and
if those instead of clay if they were
carrying a B on Bay you'd be getting a
beautiful delivery to the mucosal immune
system alright so this is the almost
last slide here's what our
candidate by mail and CD 910 carrier
vaccine against bomani I might look like
we can integrate on W into the Gua be a
locust we can integrate aren't they into
the rpoS locust if one of those was less
than mutagenic than the other let's say
aunt W was less energetic immunogenic we
could also integrate that into the HTR a
locust and we would have pag L on an SS
be stabilized plasmid okay so in summary
you know we think that attenuated s
Taiki live vaccine strains represent a
remarkably flexible platform for
developing multivalent carrier vaccines
okay we we hopefully I've convinced you
that a marriage between plasma based and
chromosomal expression systems it will
be very efficient at expressing high
levels of foreign antigens without over
attenuating the strain with subsequent
loss of kerry vaccine and immunogenicity
achieve the balance okay I think I've
shown reasonably clearly that foreign
antigens expressed on the surface or
exported are more immuno genic than
cytoplasmic Li expressed proteins
perhaps more importantly if we can get
them out to the surface we've developed
an inducible not constitutive outer
membrane vesicle system for delivery
efficient delivery of these of these
foreign antigens as vesicles to the
mucosal immune system and last but not
least your if you remember the surface
labeling experiment that we did we know
you notice that I only got about 60%
surface expression so of course I'm
tweaking that right now to see if I can
get 80% surface expression in other
words I'm always trying to optimize this
to the best I possibly can okay and last
but not least I didn't do this by myself
we've got engineers we've got
immunologists and we've got what I call
the heavy hitters which are the senior
senior senior investigators at the
Center for vaccine
Belman that have kept me out of trouble
more often than I care to admit thank
you very much for your attention thank
you dr. Gailen for that informative
presentation we will now start the Q&A
portion of the webinar and we'll address
some of the most commonly asked
questions by our beers if you have any
questions you'd like to ask we just do
so now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen
and click the send button our speaker
will follow up with your questions via
email let's get started our first
question is is your technology limited
only to outer membrane protein antigens
what if you wish to target an antigen
not normally exported to the outer
membrane okay so we actually we
presented some data around in the middle
of the presentation where we were
developing a vaccine against anthrax and
if you recall PA 83 is normally not
exported to the surface so it was
cytoplasmic Lee expressed however when
we fused that to cly a so that we could
move it out to the surface
it became efficiently exported to the
surface and when we tested those
constructs in non-human primates the
exported version of PA 83 became much
more immunogenic so I would I could use
cly a to move antigens to the surface or
I might be able to identify in the
future another carrier protein that can
move things out to the surface all right
and we're actually gonna only have time
for one more question
why have you only used an intranasal
model for immunization using ant in uted
s typhi carrier vaccines can't you use
intradermal Amenia immunization or some
other route okay so we can't
we can't use carrier vaccine live
bacterial vaccine strains cannot be used
in intradermal immunizations because
they would be very reactive genic
because of the lip of pious act right on
the outside of the cell with the advent
of pag L because pag L detoxifies lipid
a I still wouldn't use Tigh feedbacks at
carrier vaccines for entered dermal
intra dermal immunization but I have the
option now of purifying the outer
membrane vesicles that are induced by
pag L which are less reactive genic and
I could use them in a heterologous prime
boost for parenteral boosting with
recombinant om V's okay well I would
like to once again thank dr. Gailen for
his presentation I would also like to
thank lab Rouge for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through December of
2018
you will receive an email from libraries
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay we share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's event that's all
for now thank you for joining us we hope
to see you again soon goodbye